thank you so much for being here today
and thank you for connecting to us I'm
excited to talk about monitoring because
I believe it's very important to make
sure that all services we deploy to
production Works safe and sound so today
my talk will be dedicated to stay in
alert and I'm going to share with you
some thoughts on how you can implement
the alternative way to monitor your
model alternative to this traditional
one when we build live dashboards and I
hope maybe someone will be inspired at
the end of the child and apply this to
your production machine learning Based
Services
so my name is Emily I will be here like
till the end of the conference so if you
have some questions we can discuss it
later or even later later so I will be
here
ends up now I'm CTO and Governor at
evidently which is the startup where we
build the tool to validate and meet our
machine learning models and honestly
this work was inspired by my previous
experience of helping companies to build
machine learning based Solutions and
deploy them to production together with
many different companies we faced a lot
of issues related to data quality data
Integrity models performance in
production and this is why I decided to
invest a lot of time into building such
tools and today I'm going to share some
ideas on how we can Implement
performance monitor information learning
everybody know that machine learning
models needs to be monitored because of
data drift concept drift and many many
potential and real problems with data
and models quality so basically to make
sure that models work we need to
implement monitoring
luckily we have production software
services for ages so we know how to
build monitoring for Software System
basically the traditional scheme for
monitoring looks somewhat like that if
you have our rest API service in
production basically what we do is we
are logging all the requests and our
goal is to implement something like
real-time dashboard with a lot of
metrics and alerts so that you can
understand in real time or in real time
how our service operates so basically
what you generally do is we have our
request data we try to calculate a lot
of metrics which we can basically derive
from these event logs then we have to
expose endpoint for example Matrix and
we really want to expose the end points
because we want to pull our Matrix more
or less in real time because we need to
understand what is happening right now
not like five minutes ago right and we
basically use something like parameters
Source or maybe something else the
service which can pull data from our
Production service and then store it as
the time series metrics because based on
this time series metrics you can
Implement any dashboards we want and we
also have a lot of tools to do in that
for example zabix or grafana where you
can query your data source and build any
metrics that you want to monitor
together with alerts of course
tools like premiitals not only supports
pool so if you prefer to you can push
data there of course it will be more
delay but that's also possible so it's
not limited to pulling and that's how
our traditional monitoring solution
looks like basically the most
straightforward idea I believe is to
just reuse the same scheme but add a
couple of data related metrics
when you look at this
from points of Matrix you will see that
together with the standard service
Health metrics like latency or memory
usage we have something related to data
right it's data quality data drift
concept drift model performance and a
lot of such metrics so the idea is or
the question is the follows can you just
calculate a lot of machine learning
related metrics and add them to our
metric storage so that later we can just
query and visualize those metrics in our
dashboard
basically the idea sounds very good but
as usual there are some potential
problems here so first let's quickly
take a look at what data we are dealing
with to
figure out the source of potential
problems so basically when it comes to
software monitoring metrics we don't
really calculate metric basically what
we do is we derive some information from
our
requests and it's a lot of technical
metrics like
a time of response or amount of used
memory right so we don't really need to
use any algorithm to calculate that we
just need to parse our request and like
store all this data but when it comes to
machine learning models it's not exactly
like this because it's not always enough
to just parse our logs right because we
have a lot of raw data we need to
transform it into features we need to
calculate Matrix we need to have ground
rules sometimes to calculate some error
or quality related metrics so it's not
that straightforward
and now I want to share
some potential list of Matrix one might
one might want to calculate and then
discuss where we can potentially have
some difficulties so first of all I
believe everybody I agree that when
something is wrong with our machine
learning model that's because the date
is wrong right this is why we need to
monitor data quality and data Integrity
metrics start from something pretty
straightforward like number of columns
or share of missing values and move to
the distributions of features out range
values top features drifts and stuff
like that together with data we are
quite interested in model performance
right so this is the reason why we need
to analyze models output models output
distribution to make sure it stays
exactly as we expected Target drift if
you have access to Target data and batch
of machine learning quality metrics like
Precision recall log loss for
classification problems or mean absolute
error and stuff for regression models so
quite a lot of metrics
what's interesting about those metrics
that we not always can just go to our
event logs and calculate them okay so
because for example some metrics are
pretty often delayed because for many
many cases we do not have our own ground
choose from the very beginning right
especially if you're trying to predict
something for example predict the demand
for some products or some services and
our prediction Horizon is quite long for
example month or two then we need to
wait until this time pass and only after
that you can derive this Target and
calculate things like Precision recall
or even Target drift because we need to
have this target so it doesn't really
um easily integrates in the traditional
monitoring because in traditional
monitoring we are used to getting data
without any delay and just
visualize it in our dashboard so delayed
data is the first issue here
so second is that there are a lot of
metrics that need to be calculated and
we need to implement this algorithm for
a calculation of those metrics and the
problem here is that when it comes to
memory usage or latency we just derive
those data from the logs when it comes
to Precision recall or review detections
we cannot do that exactly because we
need to perform some post-processing of
those data right and there are basically
two places where we can do that in our
service when we send this data to the
premises for example or when parameters
pull this data from our service but you
don't really help you with that because
we do not want to use any memory or
other resources to like calculating Rift
because well why we prefer to save as
much time as possible for and resources
for our service and there are second
option we can do calculate all those
metrics on the dashboard side right so
in this case we need to be like SQL Guru
or foreign
query which calculates drifts that's
hard believe me that's hard so when it
comes to Google a just average or
something or Max or something this girl
is perfect but when it comes to
something more complicated then you need
to validate those queries and this is
why basically it's much better to
already like log the value in the format
when you just need to then calculate
average or other statistics on top of
already calculated values no no like row
raw data
so we have more issues here sometimes
you need to have not only current locks
from logs from most recent moment of
time but also some reference data to
calculate metrics because for example
when it comes to stuff like data drift
basically data drift is about comparing
the behavior of our current data with
the ones from the previous moment of
time for example from our validation
test or hand-picked golden set or even
sometimes from training data which I do
not recommend but still sometimes it's
happening so we need to have two data
sets and we need to compare
distributions from our features on top
of this reference data and current data
and it doesn't very nicely relies into
the monitoring scheme because loads in
huge reference data when you build in
some metrics in real time that's
generally not what we want to do
especially if our reference data set is
quite huge right and moreover when it
comes to calculation General metrics
what you're trying to do basically is to
use incremental calculations I mean just
collect more data from logs and then
update our counters or just upload those
dates in time something like this but
when it comes to data drift which is
pretty often equals to some statistical
test calculations it doesn't really make
sense to update your p-value after each
new object you get from the log spread
because it doesn't really change that
fast basically you better collect a
bunch of data and only after you get
this batch of data you like update your
drift estimation right so that's why
it's not always that handy to
recalculate those metrics in real time
finally I just want to mention that
there are a lot of customization here
because when it comes to traditional
software if you have like several
Production Services in your company and
you want to monitor for like latency and
response time you can basically reuse
the same thresholds right so if you even
even if you have like a lot of
Production Services you could possibly
split it into two groups uh super
critical and just critical right because
everything in production is critical and
specify like different expectations or
thresholds for this memory and time
related metrics but when it comes to
machine learning models it literally
doesn't work like that because for some
models like 90 of accuracy is great for
others ninety percent of accuracy is
disaster so we really need to customize
all these thresholds for different
models and if you have thousands of such
models in production you really spend
like man hours into like customizing of
those old trash goals and now one
actually wants to do that
so it's really rare when you can do it
automatically but there are some
solutions which could help is that so
now I believe we see the potential
problems with the implementing
monitoring in the very same way
comparing to a traditional software
monitoring and I want to suggest a kind
of alternative way to doing that
so together with traditional monitoring
and I'm not saying like telling like
instead it's more together because
anyway we are talking about Production
Services so we need to monitor service
Health right so this dashboard is like
mandatory but together with that you can
add one more and I want to suggest try
to use test based monitoring
which basically
looks pretty interesting instead of
having the um online updated
calculations we could implement it as
the pipelines so basically what we can
do is schedule pipelines which
calculates tests for us so that we can
run them in a schedule and then lock the
results to for example the same data
storage as we use for traditional
monitoring and then visualize it in some
dashboards even in the same dashboards
comparing to traditional monitoring
because tools like grafana or xavix or
many many other bi tools supports
different data storages right so if you
use for example parameters for service
Health monitoring you can also use the
postgresql for your machine learning
related metrics and visualize it in the
same dashboards of course in different
like tabs or different panels but the
tool will be the same which is pretty
nice so the idea is to implement and the
monitoring as pipeline jobs which we run
in a schedule
and now let's quickly see how it can
help
uh basically when we have the issue with
the reference data set what we can do is
just implement it as a pipeline in this
case we will have much less memory and
latency requirements because we already
moved from real time to batch so we can
spend quite a lot of time and
calculations so just to read all those
data calculate all those metrics and be
happy with that because you have quite a
lot of resources for that
this ground shoes it's much easier
because we can easily split our tests
into
separated jobs right and jobs that do
not need any ground rules you can
calculate with a schedule like once per
minute or less once per an hour and
other tests which really require
requires to have this ground truth
generally it's tests which depends on
the
Targets in order to calculate some
quality metrics or error based metrics
we can just make some dependency like we
calculate all those tests and metrics
only after we successfully loaded the
target data right for pipelines it's
pretty simple because there are a lot of
tools like airflow and prefect which
supports dependency between tasks so you
can implement it
when it comes to threshold customization
there are some tools which can help with
that so basically tools like Great
Expectations tools like do like deep
check like evidently we allowed to use
reference data set for threshold
calculations so instead of manually
selecting threshold for each for example
drift detection for each feature or for
Quality metric for each model you can
spend more resources integrating very
well reference data set and ask tool to
derive all these test conditions all
these thresholds automatically which is
quite nice especially if you have like a
lot of models then you can just optimize
it start to use it and then later like
just customize couple of thresholds
which you don't really like because you
miss too much problems or because it's
alerts too often
finally when it comes to pretty
complicated metrics
it's always good to have some pipelines
because when you come when you implement
your pipeline you're not limited to any
specific very specific programming
languages but I mean here you don't
really need to implement each task in
your pipeline by writing SQL query right
you can use some general programming
languages like Python and Implement any
complicated algorithm as a general
python function which is much easier
right because we have a lot of tools and
they have a lot of libraries packages
which can help with that so basically
import whatever you want implement it is
the python function and here you have
your Matrix which is really very nice
because when you log to your database
those metrics the only thing you need to
do finally is just calculate something
like
simple statistics on top of those Matrix
and you don't need to write any
complicated SQL queries which is quite
nice
and I want to encourage everyone who is
thinking about adding some machine
learning or data related metrics to
monitoring try out open source libraries
and see how you can do that using tests
because basically it makes a lot of
sense to calculate Matrix which are
designed to be calculated on top of
batch data in batch mode because when it
comes to Quality metrics even some
straightforward metrics like Precision
recall or main absolute error we don't
really want to like update it after
every single object right because well
we need to have some batch of objects to
see how the statistics changed right so
and if it's designed to be calculated on
top of batch model batch objects why not
to calculate it this way
so
um in evidently you can use it you can
build it having evidently installed as
the python package so here is a link
it's totally open source all tests and
Matrix metrics are available and
together with some Matrix and tests
which you can calculate and output in a
Json format which is the best for
automation because well basically we
need to log it somewhere and then
visualize for example in grafana if you
still do not have monitoring you can
just visualize it in Python and see how
it looks like but that's not the
scenario I suggest four minutes or just
for like testing validation for
monitoring better and Json because
and um it has very simple syntaxes so
basically you can just create test Suite
list all the tests you want specify some
variables I mean some features some
conditions and it works for you but if
you don't want to do that you have
pretty nice presets which are
uh quite good for some specific case
like getting new labeled data or getting
a new batch of predictions and just call
that and see what else there are and
then later customize it
the final architecture might be very
very similar so
um basically together with the existing
service Health monitoring you can just
add a couple of pipelines which works in
a schedule and basically write the
result date in the separate storage so
you can just for example in grafana
create button and panel use another data
source and it will be in the same
dashboard so no need to create more and
more architectural solution just add
some results of the tests and finally
they still have like two minutes I
wanted to say that it works not only for
real-time Solutions but also for bytes
right so I start from real time because
it's a bit more complicated I would say
and when you have your machine learning
model deployed as the rest API service
you really have quite like a lot of
pressure for monitoring but when it
comes to batch it also works very nice
because well if you use something like
this like you um
collect and combine to combine your data
from many many different sources then
you perform something like join and
pre-processing derive features calculate
model create the outputs and then use it
for example like in the slides it's um
might be some marketing campaign that
you are trying to optimize with help of
machine learning model so you generate
some scores and based on this course
you're like creating your marketing
campaign and doing for example email
settings right so in this case you can
also use continuous testing
it will be even more straightforward
comparing to the rest API Services
because you can basically split your
pipeline into steps it will be split in
splitted into steps because it's
generally implemented like that and
basically if you start from the loading
of new data badge we can implement the
tests like after each step of the
pipeline for example after new batch of
data arrives you can run the set of
tests for data stability like data
scheme check like column types check
like missing values checks so something
pretty straightforward I believe it like
solve like 90 of problems as usual then
you can for example check your data for
drift if you know that you have strong
seasonality or like you assume that that
might be might be some
shifts in your data then when you get
new labels of course check for
performance right I mean quality related
metrics and basically
if all checks has passed you can retrain
your data on top of new models and check
model quality right so that's how you
can integrate this continuous testing in
your battery models and this is the good
news because you can reuse the existing
testing scheme for both
virtually deployed and Trust API
deployed models which I believe nice
especially if you have both models in
production in your company and you don't
really want to spend
as much resources as you spend for model
building for monitorium right it's like
shouldn't be simpler and faster
so to sum up I want to say that even if
you have your machine learning services
in real time deployed with API you might
still monitor them in batch that's like
that that's okay I know that it's
sometimes sounds a bit
like strange because well if you have
model deployed in real time you prefer
to have monitoring in real time but when
it comes to machine learning model there
are a lot of metrics designed to be
calculated in the batch mod this is why
I strongly believe that for machine
learning Services we can just add a part
of monitoring as a batch testing and it
will be perfectly fine
so when it comes to testing it's much
more lightweight in terms of
architecture because when we calculate
something in batch mode we have much
less limits in terms of resources
dependencies and memory usage so we can
allow ourselves pretty complicated
algorithms for example for drift
detections like statistical tests
distances and many many different things
and finally
if you have not only rest API but batch
models and you don't want to customize
your testing pipeline that's used very
well because basically it's much easier
to use the same scheme for batch and uh
real-time models why not to reuse that
so my final thought would be at least
consider using continuous testing for
rest API models and if you have any
questions or suggestions or arguments
why you shouldn't do that I will be
happy to discuss that thank you so much
[Applause]
do I have sound yes thank you so much
for a very interesting talk and we have
multiple questions on Lido for you
and the most upwarded question currently
is what do you think about Auto
retraining models based on drift or
other metrics going the wrong way in
quotation marks
any problems or challenges with that oh
wow that's very nice questions question
um yes I think there are quite a lot of
challenges with that first of all I'm
like totally for outdoor training models
because when you have a lot you don't
really want to have your data sense it's
manually retraining those models right
so it needs to be automated but if we
use only drift detection for retraining
new models we can quite spend our spend
our resources for training models
because together with like shifts we
need to make sure that you have enough
data to retrain model right because if
you just detected the shift maybe we do
not still have enough data to for a
model to learn the pattern right so
maybe we still need to wait for quite a
lot of time to collect new data and I
believe it can be implemented in
Ultimate automated weight but together
with data drift I would analyze more
Magics to make sure that you have enough
resources enough data to train new model
and to make sure that it's actually
something that makes sense because
together we together with retraining
model we can um react differently for
example if we have like a fallback
system we might switch from the machine
learning approach to some statistical
based or rule-based or even send our
data to manual review if you're working
in the medicine sphere right for some
short period of time until we collect
enough data so I would think I believe
it should be implemented with respect to
a problem statement and considering
other two retraining model approach to
react on drift
yeah I think like this
thank you very much
also quite some people seem to be
interested in how to get ground Truth
for your metrics
this
follow-up sentence here is does somebody
check batches at random
okay so let me start from the fact that
it's really depends on the task and I
love data sense because you pretty much
can say it for any question depend on
the task right and that's it but
generally we get our ground truths from
some automated systems for example when
it comes to some demand forecasting
generally we get those data from like
other data sources when the Horizon has
passed or
um they might be they there might be
some pipelines which calculates for us
ground Shoes by querying the external
data sources and to load this data for
us so basically what I would do from the
pipeline automation point of view I
would implement this ground truth
loading as the
task which is scheduled by a time and
then implements The Matrix and tests
about the data quality as the dependent
for the slowing ground shoes and run it
only after we get these ground juice I
think some somehow like this but of
course it depends if we load data
manually it doesn't work obviously and
in this case you just need to try I
believe figure out how often we do that
and maybe come up with some solution
where someone can like drag and drop
these targets and run test calculations
I'm not big fan of that but anyway it's
better than just ignore those metrics
right so better to automate that but if
you cannot learn some user-friendly
interfaces
thank you again the next question is
that you made a distinction between
model quality and performance can you
explain the difference here what you
meant by the distinction uh yeah sure
basically when it comes to model quality
we somehow
um
thinking and talking about error based
metrics like Precision recall manipulate
error and stuff like that but when it
comes to
production machine learning Based
Services we are generally interested
interested in more product related
metrics for example something related to
cost efficiency or reduction of human
hours and stuff like this and sometimes
it might happen that our model still
behaves quite well in terms of for
example accuracy or Precision but it's
already started to work much worse in
terms of our business metrics for
example our model might be trained to a
little underestimate your demand and
that was okay in terms of your business
problem but later with data drift it
starts to overestimate your demand and
this might be a disaster from a business
point of view right and in this case you
might miss it from the data from model
quality Matrix but if you calculate also
business related magic if you like
definitely see that and react
so we might have time left for one more
question cool
um do you have advice on how to detect
data and prediction drift in computer
vision applications
oh that's hard and that's hard for me at
least because I'm more work with the
tabular data and it's a little bit with
encoders so this is the source of my
answer I would say that when it comes to
computer vision models I personally
would work with encoders because
generally at some point we use this we
work with those data as with vectors
right and when you come your encoders
there are many ways how you can compare
that basically it moves us to the
problem of multivariate variable drift
detection right because this encoders
they are quite large nowadays and
basically there are several approaches
like using machine learning models for
those I mean if you have your data as
encoders from reference data and from
current one you can try and you can
train a binary classifier model which
we'll try to distinguish between
reference and current data and if model
is successful enough then there is some
differences right and you can treat is
treat this results as a drift like rock
receiver operation curve as the drift
detection right and there are more
statistical related ways I don't know if
you have time to unfortunately no no we
need to come to an end then just the
list like MMG tests ratio of drifted
features if we treat each Vector
component as the separate one something
like this
thank you so much for a very interesting
talk
thank you
[Applause]